uh thank you for staying uh up to now
uh my name is chain uh
and i've just graduated from usc and
then i will go to mit as a postdoc and i
will start to
teach at uva cs department
from next fall
so my research is about online learning
it's a
about the interaction between learner
and environment
and
they have a repeated interactions
learner in everyone picks an action and
the environment will have some feedback
to the learner
and in this talk i will focus on bandit
feedback meaning that the feedback is
like the reward for the chosen action
so as an example the learner is like a
recommended system and then it can
recommend
apple to the user
then the user will have some feedback
for the item that you recommend
but the recommender system will not know
the feedback for the items that it does
not uh recommend
and because of this reason bending
feedback together with the
non-stationarity will have some
challenge and what do i mean by this
so consider a
user which has a
preference over different kinds of
movies but the preference will change
over time
as you can see from the picture
so if i'm a recommender system
i will recommend it the user with some
movies
and you can see that the cross are like
recommenders choice
so in the beginning it will explore the
two kinds of movies but you then soon
find that the user like romance movie
much more than a horror movie
so
it will uh at the later phase it will
just recommend the romance movie and
because it does not
observe the feedback for the horror
movie it will it might
it does not find that it becomes better
so we can see that this is not good
and the solution for this is that the
system has to have some extra
exploration for those actions that looks
very bad before
so you can see there are two kinds of
exploration one is the initial
exploration
whose goal is to resolve uncertainty and
the principle of this is
like optimism in the face of uncertainty
but the extra exploration is also needed
for the non-stationary case the goal is
to discover changes
and similarly if we if the feedback is
some adversarial corruption
okay
this the situation is very similar there
are a brand
that is actually good and the other is
actually bad but if there are some fake
ratings inserted for this good item
so in the beginning
well if the recommended system is not
aware of the possible possibility of the
corruption it will make some
false decision in the long run
the solution is again you need to have
some extra
exploration to correct those previous
corruptions
so we can see that uh
for a corrupted environment or
non-station environment there are
an amount of initial exploration
and the other amount of
extra exploration
and the more the non-stationarity or the
more the corruption
the extra exploration should be more
but the challenge is that how to use the
right amount of exploration without
prior knowledge on the amount of
corruption for the amount of
non-stationarity
yeah so this is actually a challenging
problem for limited feedback setting
so if you don't use the correct amount
you may suffer uh from over exploration
or underexploration which both hurts the
performance
so there are several works in my phd
study that tried to address
prior knowledge related issues
and
i will mostly talk about the first and
if time allows i will talk about the
third but i will actually
give a 45 minutes talk next week for the
third paper
the first one is about multy on bandits
i think this is a protocol that
most of you might be familiar with
and in each round the environment can
choose a
reward vector which could be adversarial
chosen or
from id
id distribution and the learner chooses
an action and observes the reward
and we look at the regret
for this problem there are two
or two kinds of uh
two kinds of famous uh algorithms one is
thompson sam thing and ucb algorithm and
the other is a exp3 algorithm
for thomson sampling or ucb it has a
very good performance when there is no
corruption but you shouldn't the
performance shouldn't degrade to a
linear in t
and there's a small amount of option
on the other hand exp3 will have a
square root t regret
no matter
how much is the corruption
but you can see that in order to achieve
the
good performance you have to have a
prior knowledge about the corruption in
order to choose a suitable algorithm so
this is now prior knowledge free
to address this issue there are several
works
that get the best of both worlds
but you can see from this curve it's
still not so satisfying because
it's optimal uh for the two extreme but
it's not smoothly interpolating between
the two extreme points
and what we find is that if you use a
very simple algorithm that is on
a linear descent plus log barrier as a
regularizer you can actually achieve a
smoothly degrade performance between the
two extreme and this is like the regret
bomb
it's parameter free and prior knowledge
so in this work uh
our contribution is that actually this
uh
unlimited descent clause log barrier uh
regularizer is not
not firstly started by us but
uh our contribution is that we discover
the power of this combination in terms
of the best of both world problem and
adaptivity against the corruption
and there are also important
improvements over our work including the
martin selden's seminal work and ethos
work
and zimmer
seldom uh julian zimmer will actually
talk about his paper next week
okay so now we go beyond martial bandit
and study reinforcement learning under
corruption
the protocol is like we study a finite
horizon fixed horizon mdp in every round
the environment will decide whether to
corrupt mdp in the current episode
then the learner will interact with this
ndp for one episode an episode will
include edge steps
the regret is the best policy total
reward and
minus the learner's total reward
and let's define c as the total number
of corrupted episodes
different from the multi-unbanded case
where square root c is possible
in the
mdp case you need to the lower bound has
a
linear term in c unless you want to pay
a exponential in h regret
so what are the
known results in previous work when c is
known you can achieve optimal bound very
easy
okay
but if c is not known
this problem is first started by
stardoris at all
you can see that all the bounce is not
optimal and our contribution is that we
bridge the gap between the non-c and
unknown c case
through a reduction
uh actually in our paper we design a
meta algorithm which
gives the reduction
and the input to the meta algorithm is
that near optimal regrets
an algorithm with a near optimal regret
under unknown c
and
you can turn it into an algorithm that
has near optimal regret under unknown c
so this bridge the uh known c and
unknown z case
and the idea of algorithm is to run
multiple base algorithms with different
hypotheses on c
this idea has come from previous work
and then we perform some careful model
selection procedure
okay so as i said i will skip this one
and the summary is that
if you have limited feedback like in
banded setting or rl
and you have unknown power of adversary
or unknown
environment change
it's very tricky to find the optimal
amount of exploration
and our goal to try to match the
performance performances
of the unknown case to the known case
and
our results is like close the gaps and
develop some general tools
that that deal with this kind of problem
and finally i want to summarize with
some of my interests so
my study
phd study is mostly about reinforcement
learning bandits online learning and
learning games
and what i try to explore
recently are about like several offline
problems and control problems and there
are some new areas that i learned
in this
program
so i also
hope that
somebody can chat with me
about these topics and thank you
thank you
[Applause]
any questions yeah
so
so i was wondering when you're seeing
that the
arrivals are sort of stochastic with
corruption
there may not be a unique way to look at
the process in hindsight and figure out
what was the stochastic part and what
was the corruption part
like if somebody told you there was a
slightly different stochastic process
with a slightly different corruption
bound
you may not be able to distinguish
between these two models so
you have a sense of like it feels like
the bound should really depend on some
kind of complexity measure of the
process and do you know if there
any attempts towards doing that
oh
i don't know okay i'm not sure so
what what you mean we can maybe the
learner cannot tell the difference
between that
i can imagine all your bonds would be
true for any stochastic process plus
corruption which would in some sense
explain your process
and so simultaneously like you're
actually getting many you're getting the
best of many different bonds
which
suggests that there's something just
special about
the input itself like there's some
complexity of the input which
will lead to what what the right bound
is
and i have no idea how to even define
this but i don't know i don't okay
that's why it's a question
no it's not so clear to me let's discuss
it
hey any
other questions
i know it's been a long day
long and hot day
well of course
there's a reception right outside so you
can ask questions there to all the
speakers so yeah let's uh thank the
speakers of this session again
[Applause]
so i shout out to all the speakers today
i think the the quality of talks and the
works they presented was all
consistently high and inspiring so
thanks everyone for the lovely talks and
we will have the second installment of
that uh tomorrow just in the morning so
uh
just two sessions tomorrow morning to
round this off so again thanks everyone
for the lovely talks and uh and the
audience for attending
and there's a reception um right right
now so please stick around for that
but
[Music]